at first glance it could be the us
military but the flags and the flowing
hair and beards soon tell you this is
the taliban enjoying the spoils of war
this convoy of what they call special
forces soldiers is here to secure the
airport
it's a priority for them to get it up
and running again if they are to govern
the country
and equipment damaged by us forces shows
how much needs to be done
as well as helicopters the control tower
and even power generators lie in ruin
there are some signs of normality as
well as aid the first domestic flights
have resumed after repairs by a team of
engineers from qatari
a working airport
cardboard is understand why
afghanistan is heavily reliant on
foreign aid a third of the country
doesn't have enough to eat according to
the united nations and the cost of
living is soaring
the taliban says it will after days of
delays announce its new government this
week one of its many challenges will be
preventing an economic collapse
but the movement still doesn't control
the entire country there are reports of
fierce fighting in the panshir valley
where the national resistance front is
holding out
the fear is afghanistan could once again
be plunged into civil war
alex rossi sky news islamabad